hey everyone how's it going so the next
couple of videos I'm going to be
answering some of the most common
questions I get in my comments and
messages this being the first hey while
you go I'm trying to figure out what to
major in to become a software engineer
my school offers X Y and C what should I
do
so first of all thing is to everyone who
has written in with this question all
y'all are probably in college or are
just supposed to start and I know that
making the decision for choosing what to
major in it is stressful so let me
bottom-line my answer by saying it
really depends on what you want um when
you go that's not a that's not a real
answer let me elaborate most
universities offer a computer science
degree which is the most popular major
to become a software engineer wait
what's the difference between computer
science and software engineering cuz I
know I've heard like you study computer
science to become a software engineer
but like I don't really get that you
know oh that's a great question think of
computer science as the study of
computers and software and software
engineering is the application side of
that study it's kind of like studying
music theory and becoming a singer maybe
as a computer science major you might
learn things like the inner workings of
an operating system how computers
understand language and code or
efficient algorithms to look through
data and as a software engineer I use
these foundational concepts that work to
build cool stuff with other software
engineers who also share the same
knowledge by the way if you're
interested to hear about how I chose my
major I made a video about my journey
into software engineering so don't
forget to check that out too so to start
there are a lot of majors available in
the computer science and software
engineering world schools could have up
to like five different major options and
because there isn't an objectively right
way to get into software engineering
there isn't an objectively correct major
to choose in order to become a software
engineer setting computer science at one
school might be really different from
study computer science at another school
and that's
because they have a different set of
professors and different curriculums for
each major on a resume whether you study
computer science or computer engineering
or software engineering honestly doesn't
really matter that much it's not the
most important criteria that recruiters
and companies are looking for in my
opinion the most important thing to
consider when choosing your major is to
find a program that matches your
strengths your weaknesses your learning
style and what you want to do in life
ask yourself questions like what piques
your interest in computers and software
do you learn well in small or large
group settings what type of tech job do
you want what company do you see
yourself working for in the future
because there are so many different
dimensions to being a software engineer
thinking about these questions can give
you an idea of which direction you want
to head towards keep in mind that you
don't have to be like super passionate
about any of the answers that you gave
to these questions being kind of
interested in something is good enough
to pursue that path these answers are
actually likely to change over time but
asking yourself these questions will get
the ball rolling towards figuring out
what you want to do after you ask
yourself these questions consider your
resources talk to professor's advisers
classmates graduates and get advice on
what you should major it and based on
what you want to do ask questions that
are important to you based on what you
want to do during and after college you
can ask questions like what do people
who major in X go on to do after
graduation of this school how does a
program set up students to find jobs
after graduation
if you major in why are there lots of
cool research opportunities for students
your major is an important part of your
path to becoming the software engineer
you want to be and if you're uncertain
that's ok too your major isn't an
ultimatum and what you major in doesn't
determine how successful it will be as a
software engineer there are lots of
other aspects beyond your major but this
is a big decision and it's an exciting
time so I do recommend taking the time
to figure out what you want if you have
any questions about this or maybe you
want to tell us how you got into your
major leave a comment down below I would
love to hear some awesome stories about
this
all right that's it thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to hit the
subscribe button for new videos almost
every week and give this video a thumbs
up if you thought this was helpful I'll
see you all next time bye
[Music]